but so emergency evacuation of the US
but can we take that as right I think it
knows where we are yeah okay apologies
for absence obviously we've got George
no one else non-members attending
welcome Julie Betsy here Thank You
minutes meeting on the 5th of September
is it good which I signed there was a
true copy anything there's any member
wishes to roll not on the current agenda
thank you any declarations of interest
please
should any arise during the meeting
please raise and then we'll make sure
they're militate item five matters
referred to this executive ever imports
from other committees there are none so
we go straight into item 6 which is the
quarter to 1819 financial management
performance report and I believe so
councillor Smith is going to lead us on
this one very far I think I just want to
pick out a highlight is that this report
reflects a well-managed Council it
reflects prudent financial decisions it
reflects our staff working extremely
efficiently and we do have to take some
credit ourselves in that as members
we've helped to see and oversee this the
this this really positive position where
were were in a position where we're
looking at managing the budget and
having some surplus at the end of the
year
so I think it's a good news story all
round but for the detail I'll I'll pass
you over to and yes so as I said this is
the quarter to four natural ones report
and the first water report was shared
with council Smith his portfolio of
Davinia hasn't been notably taken twenty
meeting so this is the first meeting has
come to an end so the first reports come
to an executive meeting councilor Smith
said in terms of the revenue budget its
we're reporting very positive position
so we're projecting at the moment an
understand of eight hundred and fifty
eight thousand pounds against a net
revenue budget of nine point five
million pounds the main driver of the
underspend
is salary salary spend so we're
projecting to spend about five hundred
sixty six thousand pounds less than we
budgeted at the start of the year and
that's predominantly driven from two
reasons one we've just had a higher than
expected vacancy rate at the start of
the year so we could develop really
illegitimate the forecast that we would
have had to turnover rate that we've had
it started to the years that sparked the
driver the second one was a decision to
breathe by composers for six months
which we've now decided to pause that
see at the moment so yeah anybody any
place that became vacant was held for
six months which obviously led to and my
hire under spent on salaries and start
of that kind of career other than that
there's a couple of other areas of just
point to in terms of dispense orgy spent
is and it's been a strong bed of
breakfast accommodation in terms of the
homelessness budget has reduced compared
to last year so you'll be aware that
we've built a little bit of extra budget
and this year's is all the precious
erase last year but given our
successfulness even driving down there
are allowed to eat better breakfast
accommodation and started the year where
we're now projecting an approval at one
hundred forty three thousand pounds
against that budget policy is
potentially quite volatile won't have to
keep an eye on their arse video
vertically over the winter period and in
addition we have brought some additional
income in relation to their council tax
sharing scheme that we participating
with their county council now the
precept is of around 70,000 pounds so
there are three arrows I would just
point your attention to obviously is a
number of others and and that says
within the report which I've detailed so
if anybody wants to ask any questions
I'm happy to try and answer those in
terms of their capital budgets with
forecasting to spend 90% of our capital
program by the be by year-end of 2.8
million against the three point
budgets within that we've got some
underspend projected against our ICT
upgrades budget of around 50,000 pounds
and also we're not projected to really
spend our playground improvement budget
of 85,000 pounds so that's a couple of
the key areas where we're not quite
getting really spend our capital budget
but in most other areas we are when we
are passing to be unpracticed in that
play Aaron there's obviously a number of
performance indicators that are also
detailed within the report and indeed in
addition to the financial indicators
that we always were not but this year
onwards we are unfortunately more
general performance indicators as part
of this report whereas previously they
had just been circulated to members as
part of that and remembered drop that I
have been Marty's report and it is quite
ought to be time in terms of our
performance indicators and which I'm
happy to take questions on and there's
obviously a couple of areas that are
showing it at spread at the moment draw
attention to the housing benefit
overpayments one which is slightly below
targets at the moment so what where
housing benefit payments aren't paid we
obviously seek to recover those the soon
as possible but we're slightly behind
target for those at the moment and also
the average number of days process
benefit claims is again lagging a bit
behind
target although I would say that would
make the positive inroads in terms of
being that that sound since the start of
the year so that although they are and
below target well under my trajectory in
terms of those and another area which is
showing us red and is the number of
households in a very breakfast Takamoto
sorry yeah but in breakfast
accommodation and so I get that is zero
because obviously I we don't want
anybody in that
accomodation and as I said within the
financial report we are actually showing
an improvement compared to our previous
performance last year on that but
obviously we have still trajectory and
at this point in time and so that's sort
of them yet less positive in two pages
but the majority of the others are
showing this greeting or kizomba so
overall a very positive and you have our
performance but again yeah happy to take
any questions if anyone's got any to
them that's raised in relation to that
yeah okay yes please
Thank You general I'd like to say what
the triple-t it's something you should
all be all of us as counselors staff
officers everybody should be proud I am
in fact I have some make some firm
decisions about staffing at which I've
had a couple of criticisms over but I'll
stand by the decisions and as my Amir
said and there was a bit of a drop in
some benefits tried to do over time but
unfortunately because when I'm trying to
log on to the weekends the computer
systems been down so that hasn't helped
but they're willing and I think it's
good report I think we should all be
proud I agree thank you no it's just an
observation actually and yes it actually
comes on our agenda very
first time strangely enough just
actually something that Simon said very
early on though the council's priorities
and point one to become financially
self-sufficient and you know I think you
know we've really really been moving it
in a strong direction bearing in mind
you know we possibly receive from the
government and we're having to supply
uphill somewhat but you know I think
we're doing such a good job
realistically I think you should be
acknowledged that that's well done that
we're meeting that very very informed
number one bullet point thank you very
much yes absolutely
I think with the the targets the one
that Noemi mentioned about bed and
breakfast and a target of zero it's very
difficult for us to manage and I don't
think there are many councils that will
be doing better than we've done in the
last 12 months in bringing in bringing
forward initiatives to deal with home
homelessness and although the target is
something we have to be measured against
and it's read there's a positive story
behind that and if anyone comments that
that's something that we're failing in I
think we need to robustly defend and let
them know from what we've done the last
12 months because people presenting
themselves a bed and breakfast that
that's beyond control the actions that
we take after that I'll be on doctor are
all within our control and we mounted
very positively in that area
well I'll just echo what councillor
Smith said laughing Louise's teams were
exceptionally hard over the last 12
months I mean it city where we were at a
number of women P and B I think was in
the fruit for the work items in Francis
Collins house and South Street he may
like move on simple accommodation but we
had got a silt up in terms of meals they
couldn't move on seen tremendous
progress in the last 12 months but it
might've known as a caution is that
we've got to keep on a ball in the next
12 months we don't want to see those
numbers picking back up again and
obviously we are relying on how I wasn't
coming on stream we've got those
lobsters orbital to move into but
certainly I think is very exceptional 12
Bronxville Louise are in the team yeah
okay no breakout can only echo what
everybody else is saying I think it's
fantastic than it's certainly very very
good George who did something apologies
I couldn't be here this evening he did
and I searched but I can't find it he
did phrase a query but one of the items
was the budget the one area but we have
provided with the it just asked me to
raise that you say because he knew it to
be anything but now I think it's
fantastic around certainly around the
homeless and everything is coming on
stream as well which will hopefully keep
it keep it all going in the right
directions yes yes I can just just bring
up the talking points that councilor I
mentioned just to emphasize on 16.3 one
this is questioning so obviously but
there are things in there within within
planning with applications and things
like that which you know have not been
as good as we would like them to see but
I believe that with the change that is
going to be with regard to the freeze
being removed for recruitment we're
going to hope to be able to recruit more
staff and we should actually be able to
rebalance what is the deficit and which
is obviously a worry to us with regard
to making sure this planning
applications are done within the proper
time and we know that the department has
had problems but hopefully those will be
addressed and we'll be able to solve
those problems over the next few months
I understand we're actively recruiting
on that side of the boat oh yeah thank
you I just didn't come back in there and
say and yes we just because the freeze
has been lifted doesn't mean so we're
going to be recruiting left right at the
same time because we certainly have a
lot of money for that but it's a change
within the department that's going on
yeah and that's hopefully that area yeah
I mean from one point of view it's
extremely good report it shows how
well-managed our officers are actually
managing their spend and I think the
culture I think of the other officers
has changed over the years
in as much as the one time I think when
times were better I think you know
obviously the council spent up to a
budget nowadays you try and save on that
budget where you can and obviously put
that back into the pot for leaner years
and on that score yes
okay we're managing the accounts well
there's no question about that we've got
some extremely good officers who are
taking that through for us but down the
road we don't know what that where that
road leads us going into the future we
need to make sure that we build up
enough balances to get us through any
any storms if you lie they're coming on
the horizon for us
make sure that we can weather them
accordingly we don't know exactly what's
happening as far as finances are
concerned I think the budget had some
implications for us as well
with things like rates and business
rates in the future where I know the
government is saying about reductions
and then then talking about passing
those figures on to us and I always
remember the way that the right business
right where they're actually challenging
their business rights yeah let's say
there is it straight appeals and then
the government passed them on to our
Sivan and we had absolutely nothing to
do with them made us responsible for
them so you know these are the sort of
things that can happen and I think
unfortunately you don't get out for neon
with these things as they extend so I
think from that score I think it works
extremely well I do think our officers
indeed for all the diligent work that
they put forward for this but let's see
where we lie at the end of the year
because we don't even know what's coming
for the rest of the year but the
projection looks extremely good so a
haughty build-up for that thank you I
think we should have ignited chairman
not to go to any other council but for
personal reasons or not and I think you
know he's done really well on those that
absolutely yes I think it's worth
mentioning in our minutes for the
Sterling work that he's put forward for
us both through the past and wishing a
good future absolutely yeah so yes I
think we'd all agree with that right
Ricky edition mini record is to note the
revenue budget item is the it's pretty
similar to a grant we use for hot
keywords to improve that place bikes
last year so this is pretty similar
opportunity for one of our families
needed to the product in December 3rd
party contribution hundreds of lentil
communities fund for that where they
also access to forty five thousand
pounds are there they're willing to
offer and so the work will be for a
project at Swank park owners ways to
improve space there okay well I think
it's pretty good deal and then I think
we all very and 4,500 to realize an
extra forty five thousand and bad I wish
I could do that
finances but it doesn't work that way
fortunately but I think it's it's good
because we can update the equipment we
can make it safer and hopefully make
sure we've got something we can give to
area Yahoo Google people into the future
it was mentioned actually by others that
we could actually look at some equipment
for older people I don't know if that's
something that's planned at all we've
spent some of our council words on this
matter and so we're putting together a
more comprehensive range of suggestions
for well open space it across the
district's but certainly a.m. so we've
selected a sort of tail wag the dog but
was he with the funding for nine
thousand that will down what they
dictate to some extent which is putting
a series of things and how do we get
perhaps one back each quarter okay I
know there are a couple of play areas
where you can do that at the moment and
I think they've extremely popular
because I know some people were all
after the fitness regime except you know
as we get older now so I think it's
something we need to consider as we go
forward
okay and two members have any comments
at all okay members agree the
recommendation for a raise thank you
very much indeed
all right thank you very much indeed
thanks John